on on that plan and of course as we
produce it we are being guided by the
science and we will try to build the
maximum political consensus as we
produce it across all parties and simply
do the reopening that we all need to do
so how do we do on ventilators as an
example where you were really and you
know you needed them badly yeah we got
them I mean there's just no other way to
put it and I'm told that we were the
number one research State recipient at
that layers and this was you know we
were at the edge and this is life or
death stuff and we got them and we were
forever thankful for that operation
who's in charge of that and are you over
promising when you say you're going to
have no who said it but whatever the
maximum is whatever you can humanly do
we're going to have and we hope we're
going to come up with a good vaccine
Johnson & Johnson and Oxford and lots of
different great companies
representatives of our country and
sometime in some ways NIH is working
very hard and doing a terrific job
no I hope we're gonna have a vaccine and
we're going to fast-track it like you've
never seen before if we come up with a
vaccine I think they probably will we
have you know as a judge of it honestly
I am I'll tell you I'm really in charge
of it I could say somebody else I will
say we're dealing with as you know the
general and the Admiral they're very
much in charge but I think probably more
than anything I'm in charge and I'm the
one that gets blamed and I get blamed
anyway don't forget if we come up with a
vaccine in record time those sessions
are done it faster we have a lot of good
a lot of good possibilities like the
Gilead yesterday was a big thing it was
a big thing and as explained and I think
very importantly that was a step you
know I was a big step
31% step but the step means I guess
tempura with Tony yesterday was
the step means you now take another step
another all of a sudden you up to 50 60
70 but that was a very positive it was a
big step as I understand it they agree
with the scientific community that the
virus did originate in China but was not
man-made and was not genetically
modified do you agree with that as well
I haven't seen the report yet but I will
tell you if you speak to the head of
intelligence right now you speak to the
head they did say that I was given a
briefing when I said I was given it not
before and they also said that it wasn't
specific and it was not a panic briefing
it wasn't like oh we're going to be
invaded it was in January later January
and I think I think what you'll do is
you'll speak to them in fact unless mark
to make a report to you because the the
news was totally you know as usual fake
and corrupt so intelligence is doing a
report and the report turned out to be
exactly as I said everything in January
about no I'm not you didn't hear me I
said intelligence is saying it and
they're gonna give a report and it will
make you very unhappy because it makes
you so wrong
you in particular I go ahead and I do
please his governor states received 150
billion in the first years after what
are what are you going to need now to
get back on your feet what I've told the
President on that front and how do you
address with public and complaints that
the federal government should not be
bailing out of states who were badly
managed
prior to the pandemic yeah so I've been
in office two going on two and a half
years and I got elected to sort of fix
the economy and we made a lot of
progress on what I would call the legacy
issues record pension payments
stabilizing indebtedness record
surpluses and as Mike Tyson says
everyone's got a plan to get punched in
the face and we did so we we've made
we've got a plan and we're we're
comfortable with the progress that it's
gonna take a while I'm a legacy stuff
the financial assistance we need and we
need a significant amount this is a big
hit and this is somewhere in New Jersey
alone could be twenty to thirty billion
dollars but this is to allow us to keep
firefighters teachers police EMS on the
payroll serving the communities in their
hour of need and that's something that
we feel strongly about we don't see it
as a bailout we see this as a
partnership doing the right thing in
what is the worst healthcare crisis in
the history of our nation and I want to
again thank the president for an
extraordinary spirit of partnership
across the whole spectrum of our needs
and I want to reiterate that thank you I
will say that's a tough question because
you're talking about the states and
whether you call it a bailout or a lot
of money and it's a lot of it's four
years long before you were there you
can't have a better representative than
this man that I can tell you plus he's
an old Feldman's XK and what they don't
know about him he's done a great job but
he went through a big operation just
before this happened and that's a hell
of a thing it was a big deal thank you
sir we solve that problem yesterday I
expect to see the supply chain as strong
as ever may be stronger for certain
reasons we did something we got we had a
road block it was a legal roadblock more
than anything else it was a foolish
thing that nobody ever took care of for
a long time and we took care of it no I
expect things to go very smoothly
there's a lot of supply to but now
they're gonna get it and that was solved
yesterday I'm very late in the evening
well we're talking about that I know a
lot of people are talking about it but
we've given a lot of stimulus and again
we think now it's it's so great I'm so
happy that you're opening up parks and
things because that's a big step for New
Jersey because they weren't it very hard
I think that I think you're gonna see
something that's gonna surprise maybe
the world and you know with a leader of
the world we're really the leader in
this case the leader of the world and
we've done better if you look at our
deaths if you look at mortality rates if
you look at the things we're in fact I'm
gonna get a chart because it's maybe the
most impressive thing right how we've
done and that's a tribute to the
governor's and it's a tribute to the
federal government and all of us working
together what I would love you to get
that if you could deep because we're
right at the top
meaning top in a positive way of those
charts I think you're gonna see economic
numbers that are gonna be fantastic I
believe it very strongly and you're
going to start to see it with the
transition period which is number three
and quarter four you're gonna have
tremendous numbers in a tremendous times
and I think next year you're going to
really have tremendous numbers yeah are
you going to pardon him this is what you
tweeted back in December 2017 I have a
fire General in because he lied to the
vice president in the FBI you still
believe that he lied to the vice
president
yeah well when I looked at what they did
to him they tormented him dirty cups
tormented general Flynn general Flynn is
a fine man 35 years or so and the
military you don't get to be where he is
by being bad that I can tell you and
then he right at the beginning of the
administration the dirty cops came in
and you see the notes Jim I mean whether
you're on our side that side whatever I
mean I assume let's all talk about
fairness what they did to general Flynn
and by the way to Roger stone and to
others was a disaster and disgrace and
it should never be allowed to happen in
this country again and what I really
hoped could see it in tormented him in
all fairness I really hope to see
because they haven't been doing it and I
appreciate your question I hope to see
that CNN will not even apologize which
they should but just cover it fairly
because he's in the process of being
exonerated if you look at those notes
from yesterday that was total
exoneration these were dirty filthy cups
at the top of the FBI and you know the
names better than I do
and it would dishonest people now we
have to see what's going to happen but
general Flynn was treated like nobody
should and I'm not talking about
generals I'm saying like nobody in this
country should be treated and they did
it right at the beginning they did it
right Jim they did it right well look at
what they did to the guy I mean he
couldn't have known too much what was
happening they came at him with 15 buses
and he's standing in the middle of a
highway what they did to this man they
tormented him they destroyed him but
he's going to come back like I say he's
going to come back bigger and better but
what they did to him and I hear there's
a lot of other stuff coming out if I
believe everything I'm reading because I
like to stay out of it I don't have to
stay out of it at all but I like to stay
out of it and Jim what they did to him
is terrible and I hope that CNN is going
to give
fair shake and cover it is because I
think it's very important yes was it a
mistake to fire well what I wish I had
it was all the information where they
were out to get him they wanted him they
were trying to force him to lie you see
the written statements where they were
trying to force him into a position
where we can get him on a lie or can we
get him this way or that way this is
terrible this is like what happened in
and I'm not going to name the countries
because we deal with these countries
okay but what would happen in other
countries not the USA what they did to
General Flint and others and others is a
disgrace be and I hope really I hope
your networks are gonna cover it because
you know I've seen where it's the
biggest story in the world a year ago in
a year and have it Flynn Flynn Flynn and
then he's essentially exonerated now
that's not official yet but when you
read the notes how could you do anything
else and I hear this I hear there's much
I hear Jim I knew this much more coming
up I think it would be so good for CNN
if you covered it honestly and have you
reported honestly it was so good for the
network okay with that thank you all
very much
thank you thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
of course I didn't predict Khurana but I
knew we were producing too many plans
right now Boeing has to cut production
very substantially and I would not be
surprised at all if the cuts will be
people
[Music]
[Music]
it's tough to be out of work and on
unemployment many people certainly have
to provide for their families they have
to pay their bills but they're also
concerned about catching this virus and
bringing it home to the people they love
we believe an oily there any surface
accuser yeah it's a you Cartman no tira
de paula Vonda Aleta chang-chang Dede
Hyrum root Serena but abhorrent lambdas
are carry a Java in the Hadean e islet a
ram real Agra's armlet a in a lockdown
Bernie you're a fighter that word with
you I did a training email here at
church and DD heeda has ever run recent
purchases I once you combine your there
with your guys I become a policeman come
out there is no season